[Music]
all right let's go out to
hannah in dallas texas hannah what's
going on
hi dr john how are you i'm all right how
about you
kind and take it one day at a time uh-oh
so what's going on
all right no that's okay that's all
right take your time
here watch me this dude do a favor for
me i want you to take a deep breath as
you can i want you to hold it
and i'm gonna count to three okay
breathe it in as deep as you can
hold it for one two
three and then let it out
and then do it again and this time i
want you to breathe in through your nose
okay
breathe in as deep as you can hold it
one two
three and then just blow it out
that really helps and i'm glad that you
called what's up
um well a couple months ago
my husband and i lost our first daughter
oh my god
i'm so sorry
thanks
she's just a weak yeah
what a nightmare yeah
she had a chromosomal disorder and
so we we saw it coming
and so we were savoring every moment
with her but
it doesn't matter right yeah
we have a piece about like everything
that happened
and we we kind of understand it as well
as we can
but it just it doesn't take away the
pain
yeah so what are the last two months
been like
uh the first month wasn't bad we were
like as bad as it could have been you
know sure um
i feel like it was still like a lot of
shock and a lot of
times just being able to
remember her and make
honor her i guess through
writing things about her and telling
people about her but
um the past month it's been getting a
little harder
and i
i guess i don't really know very well
how to cope
and manage the grief as it's just been
getting harder so when you say getting
harder
what does that mean
fake feeling like i'm gonna cry at the
drop of a hat
all the time and i'm just thinking about
her constantly
and before it was really easy to hear
well i mean i guess it wasn't easy but
it was it didn't feel
as painful to hear about other people's
kids and other people's births
and now people like i see them
getting on with their pregnancies and
their births
um and people just talking about
passing away and like just with
older people and those things are just
starting to hit a little closer
and making me miss her more and more
how are you and your husband
i think we're doing okay i know we could
be doing better
um but
yeah i don't know so we love each other
well right it's like a miss
it just has felt like misconnection for
a while yeah
so how far along in your pregnancy did
you did you know this was coming
we were 20 weeks when he found out that
something was wrong
and how how long did you carry uh
38 weeks okay wow so another
another few months okay
so
what you described so beautifully the
last
the first month is
a really remarkable defense mechanism
our bodies have
which is almost this disconnection from
everything
just so we can get through the data data
day-to-day right
and as you're you begin to plug back in
is your body
and i hate this analogy but as it starts
to come back online
the reality of what happened hurts so
bad
and you've been grieving this for a long
time you were grieving this at 20 months
at you know 20
20 weeks right and
husbands and wives always grieve these
things differently which
then feels like there's a gap between
them and there's something
we're not okay or we could be like as
you said quote-unquote be doing better
and that spins different different alarm
systems off right so
hear me say this wherever you are right
now
is okay
and if you feel like crying real hard i
want you to have permission to cry real
hard
and if you don't want to leave the house
for a minute don't leave the house for a
minute
there's a few things i'll tell you in
here in a minute that i want to make
sure that you've got
um that you've you've
got at your fingertips to make sure
you've got people that are walking with
you in this deal
but there's not a lot of shoulds
everybody's grief looks different
everyone's looks painful everyone's
looks or not everyone looks painful some
people just
move right on other people are
devastated other people
comes in waves everyone's looks
different
tell me about this little baby's funeral
how did y'all how did y'all celebrate
her life
it was really sweet um
my husband and i both wrote uh i guess
stories about the week that we had with
her yeah
i guessed how much we left her and
i made her a little dress out of my
wedding dress
and it was oh wow really beautiful
my husband bought her a necklace three
little hearts
and uh we had
all of our family come and a lot of our
really close friends and community come
and support us
we did a slideshow we had pictures
and my husband uh
kind of gave i guess a eulogy of her
life and
just how much she changed us and how
much we love her
so hannah i've heard um
i don't i don't know the number of folks
i have talked to over the years
in a similar situation and that may be
the most beautiful
um celebration i've ever heard
it's incredible and
it doesn't mean it hurts any less and it
doesn't mean
what happened is okay it doesn't mean
that y'all aren't um
still wrestling every minute of every
day
yeah but it's beautiful and i'm glad
that you all did that that's
really remarkable so as you're
navigating this a month later
this becomes super real right and
not only that is as
it's some at some level your body is
still re-regulating itself after a
pregnancy
there's a lot going on do you have a
doctor you're continuing to work with
um kind of not really
no i think we're done with doctors no
okay i can imagine that's not a happy
place right now
so if you find yourself um increasingly
unable to function
if you increasingly i'm i'm getting out
of bed feels like i've got
a backpack full of cinder blocks on
right um
i can't move my legs out of my bed i
want you to make a phone call to your
doctor
okay and
i also want you to make sure that you
have a couple of women in your life
either they've experienced something
similar or you have 100
trust in them and you can reach out to
them
and let them know that you're my go-to
and i'm going to text you at all hours
of the night i'm going to text you
crazy things that come to my mind i'm
going to call you crying i'm going to
call you laughing and if i say hey i
need
i need tacos now you're going to come
and that they'll show up
okay do you have those people in your
life
yeah yeah i do and you trust them
i trust soap it's just i don't want to
feel i guess
like i'm i'm burdening them i know that
they'd be there but
there you go so you don't um you're
gonna have to let that go for a season
okay that's why we have other people
they hold our hands up
and our arms up when we can't
that's why we have community right
yeah so a really important place for
you to zero in soon
is with your husband okay and
um
i did not understand what my wife was
going through
in not quite the same situation but
um related i didn't get it i didn't
understand
and it was after a couple of really hard
and direct
um conversations that my eyes were
opened in a pretty significant way
and so whether you can do that directly
or he can hear that or do that with you
share that with you directly or you all
need to go get somebody that you trust
to
to sit with both of you
i want you all to make sure a you're
giving each other space to grieve
however y'all grieve
and everybody does this differently you
can't get in the grief comparison game
it's real easy for you to start saying
hey man are you going to get over this
we got to move on
and him to start saying hey when are we
going to try for all that stuff feels
so intrusive and hard and messy and
gross
and making sure y'all are setting aside
dedicated time
that y'all are on the same page and
you're both giving each other permission
to be heard and to speak and the more
you speak and the more open you feel and
the more you all reconnect
not that it makes this thing hurt less
but your
your body knows that you've got somebody
to share this burden with
it helps with the healing okay the other
other way this happens so often is one
of you starts to move on faster than the
other
the other person becomes devastated by
that and you just get into this
dance that will haunt your marriage for
years and years
it all starts and ends with you both of
you being willing to be open and
compassionate and
quiet with one another and to be able to
speak truth to each other
are you all in a position where you can
do that are you willing to try that
for sure yeah okay
at some point you'll begin to the
the hard but more light the more
optimistic turn
which is making meaning of this why us
why did that beautiful little baby have
a chromosome issue
why why did i carry to term
a beautiful kid and only get to spend
five six seven days with her
why did we have to do this why did our
families have to come up for this
why me why my husband y'all begin to
make me what are we gonna do now
and that's when you begin to take this
pain and this frustration and this why
and you turn it into so now
right you begin to make meaning out of
this thing and that looks different for
everybody whether you become a go-to
resource for folks experiencing a
similar thing whether you become
um you already are the greatest mom i've
talked to in a long time
um you become even more
um cognizant of what's coming that of
your next kid that comes along
or or or or meaning making looks
different for everybody but you'll get
there
right now isn't that time it's not to
beat yourself up for crying it's not to
beat yourself up because i can't get out
of bed it's not to beat yourself up
because i haven't talked to my husband
in a while
there's not a playbook for people's
grief right now it's to experience it
and to feel it and make sure you got
people around you
and then there's a little things make
sure you're eating right make sure
you're showering make sure you're
drinking water
make sure you get outside and go for a
walk right the little things we forget
to do we look up we haven't eaten in a
week right
um have you been there yet or you
haven't showered in a week
no i'll keep showering
good for you it's your husband that's
not gross gross
um but yeah make sure you're doing the
little things and if you don't have
somebody to text you along the way
right that will just say hey we're going
to get lunch you're eating and you'll
say i'm not hungry and they'll say well
too bad because i'm showing up with
enchiladas right whatever that looks
like but make sure you got people to
walk alongside you
here's the person i want you to really
love and honor over the next 30 to 60
days
okay hannah
cool
yeah i want hannah to write hannah a
letter
and i want hannah to acknowledge what a
great mom hannah is
i want hannah to acknowledge how much
this sucks
moms are not supposed to bury kids
they're just not it's not how
it's not supposed to work
and i want hannah to talk to hannah
about what tomorrow might look like
what the future might look like
but i want hannah to be really graceful
with hannah right now
you are right in the middle of it okay
and like i said if it gets too heavy
please be brave and call somebody
you promised me that no problem
okay it's one of the greatest honors
of my professional life to get to talk
to you
thank you
do you promise me you're gonna let
yourself cry
yeah i will good now like you got a
choice though
all right right
before we go i want you to tell me one
thing that you wrote in that letter to
your daughter
how thankful i was that
god gave her to me so that i could love
her
in that few days you had with her what
was the sliver of joy she brought you
i got to hold her and she had the
squishiest face
the little fingers and twelve toes that
were our favorites
ah they're the cutest not cute thing at
all when they're two days
right yeah and
everyone has to lie to everybody like
look how cute and they're never like oh
how cute and everyone knows everybody's
lying right
but there's nothing like that squishy
face on your chest huh
there's nothing like it yeah and there
never will be
yeah you're a brave
tough vulnerable spirit
and i'm grateful for you hannah
thank you honor that baby
honor hannah honor your marriage make
sure you reach out for help
make sure you got a group of people
walking with you make sure your gross
husband is showering
[Applause]
hello and i want you to keep us updated
on your journey here okay
um don't hesitate to write us back if
man if things
take a turn sideways give me a call back
give me a call back
oh here's one more thing you're gonna
get
listen you're gonna get the stupidest
advice
you've ever heard in your life you're
gonna get the dumbest
cliched cheeseball sayings you're gonna
start seeing
more of your friends pregnant
your the the coveted numbers are gonna
you know the people getting sick people
passing away those are gonna look like
giant neon red flashing lights it's just
your
heart and mind scanning the environment
for another opportunity for you to get
hurt
i want you to know it feels like things
are closing in on you
and they're not you're surrounded by
people who love you
you're surrounded by a guy that loves
you and you're and you're strong
and you're tough but now's not the time
for strong and tough now's the time for
weeping and mourning
thanks for honoring us hannah here's my
promise to you
there's a lot of women a lot of men
listening to this
right now who have experienced that know
somebody's experiencing that
and just hearing your heart and walking
through that
is a gift so thank you so much for
sharing that with us